hey superfans I'm Liana Galera and ET is
coming to you live from Comic Con with
the cast of the flash hey guys so grant
what's happening I'm so excited to have
you guys it's always a fun weird
interview and let's get started so hi I
want to talk about the fact that we
ended the last season on a really
emotional note as you know Barry and
iris had to say goodbye to Nora
they really formed this amazing bond
with her over those last season where's
their mindset as they go into this new
year it's a direct pickup so it's like
we're pretty much like still dealing
with the shock of it and then moving
forward after that I mean Barry is
trying aggressively to be optimistic and
move forward and probably to a fault
like not really dealing with it in all
the ways that he should be dealing with
it yeah and I think you'll see very
early on
iris kind of questions how they're both
dealing with it they you know really
talk about what the appropriate way is
to kind of grieve Nora so that they can
move forward in a positive way and get
back to team flash and do it in a way
that they can sustain themselves as a
married couple I was gonna say obviously
yes they want to continue to be there
for team flash but what about west-allen
has a couple is this gonna be something
that's gonna shake up their relationship
or maybe and make it stronger it doesn't
feel like it's I mean it's gonna shake
it up for sure some but I feel like I
mean we've had interesting scenes thus
far like this but you know there's
tension but it's we are coming together
closer in some ways it's like it's good
marital tension where it's like you're
not afraid of them getting divorced but
you know they got they got stuff to work
out like any other and it doesn't work
out then I feel like nope I know but I
feel like there's a number of well know
guys who's like we've kind of hit it off
you can't deny there's chemistry there
I'm just saying oh wow of infinite Wells
business what can you tease about this
Wells again Candice lost the lottery
there's a romance brewing then there's a
romance brewing like sometimes you just
can't stop love okay you and I've talked
about this you can't stop you can't ever
do you can be a denier facts are facts
facts are facts this is not fake news if
you don't want to unleash the wrath of
the West Allen fans you might get that I
wouldn't do that first off I consider
myself the biggest fan but the truth is
this love is bigger than so many things
you know is not bigger than the
metahuman cure because okay Lois talk to
me about Cisco he obviously thought long
and hard about this he took the
metahuman cure where does he go from
here and did he do it for love let me
just say I'm very frustrated cuz I told
time to keep it low-key
mmm-hmm okay yes but I thought you were
talking about the superhero Loki - I was
confused how's your interview going it's
going great Tom shush everyone you asked
honest a question I think things were
great Francisco actually right now
he's uh he's a happy he's a happy guy
he's got a girlfriend he's he's doing
really well at balancing that work-life
relationship so yeah we'll see how that
goes disastrously from here was the part
of team flash though yeah okay yeah he's
part of team flash he's gonna be working
as a scientist and star at STAR Labs and
as various best friend which brings us
over to Hartley first of all how are you
feeling about request for Barry's best
friend status you know you know we'll
see how it plays out yeah
I mean he's not gonna be there well yeah
exactly
Ralph in the season finale you know he
was behind the detective desk he looks
like he's really comfortable there
what's his journey gonna be this next
year we're gonna continue that and
explore that a little bit more and I
think he's really settled into his place
and team flash now and that's been super
fun to play we're gonna see a little bit
of romance a little bit of romance
supposed to talk about it I'm looking it
up the cute question for sure Academy
the chemistry's there absolutely there
it's absolutely yeah do you a question
for Danielle oh that's my next question
how cute do you think do with amazing
new killer prostitute and you've
actually had this suit for a while talk
to me about why it took so long for us
to see it we started building the suit
last year for season five and it just
you know the stories we were telling it
didn't necessarily make sense to reveal
the suit it has to come from Cisco and
no one sews like Cisco exactly I'm
really excited to see this sewing
machine so it's great I'm really excited
we're gonna kick off the season getting
to see the new suit hopefully see her be
a badass in it yeah well you're also
gonna be a badass on set as well because
you're directing another episode
congratulation very much do you know
anything about the episode can tell us
anything
um just a tiny bit I'm directing much
earlier in the season this year I'm
directing episode 6 which is great and
I'm excited I think you know we have a
new bad guy this year and I think I'll
get to play with some of his powers a
little bit great back to the bad guy
because every year Candice
you and I talk about the same subject
and every year we say hopefully it's
gonna happen was a subject reporter iris
oh yes we do talk about we talk about
this every year is already the year you
know I'm watching
this is finally the year thankfully our
new producer is super excited about it
he's wanted to see it for a long time
I've been talking about it for years I
think it's so important to see iris have
her own agency the way she did in the
comics you know it's taken a long time
to get here and we're finally gonna do
it justice she has her own office she's
starting to build up a citizen we're
gonna see a lot of new employees that
she hires so it's gonna be its own new
set new thing new vibe I'm super super
excited iris west-allen boss lady boss
lady yes oh I'm liking this does this
mean that you get a new wardrobe this
year everyone keeps asking does it mean
like I get to be fly I mean I don't know
all right let's talk about the new Big
Bad of the year ha he's like a scientist
like what's what's going on guy bad guy
so many phone-a-friend yeah what can you
tease about about your villain this year
okay he's introduced through Caitlin we
use have a history friend history of
some yeah and he is a scientist doctor
scientist he's when it's cooler than you
yes yeah he specializes in and am I
allowed to say that nothing so just say
what I've said oh yeah and apparently
he's a very nice guy
the crossover this year is gonna be the
most ambitious one that you guys have
ever taken part in how are you feeling
are you already like starting to take
your emergency because I feel like it's
just going to be the most draining
situation you've ever been is fine yeah
if you have to wait from that really
mentally right yeah I mean there's still
a ways away at this point I can't think
about that yeah you start on Monday on
Monday
have they told you the overall arc
though um it's all improv it's all
improv yeah yeah well thanks for
answering my question
trying to do a job or what only you guys
that I can be this Steven just told me
that he's playing multiple characters in
the crossover grant are you playing
multiple characters as well nothing I
know of no that's it no from I if I
phoned a friend and we've already seen
all of your characters so there's so
much over the past years that you guys
have been on our screens what is still
on your flash bucket list what would you
like to see them take on well the one
thing for me we both agree one thing for
us well what were you gonna say as a
couple I think that we both I said it
last year and I've been saying it for
years I've always wanted a Halloween
episode on our show and so yeah is that
happening I don't know that would be
cool it is happening yeah so I'm really
excited about that I don't know what
that's gonna look like but I've always
wanted to kind of explore that in our
show a little bit you could do anything
right yeah yeah welcome jack-o'-lantern
what jack-o'-lantern right I wanna watch
the bucket though you've done all the
things yeah yeah legitimately kind of
feel the same where it's like I will
just have to be surprised now everything
that I've said over the years like I
want to do this or I want to do that
we've kind of yeah exactly so I'm like
now I'll just have to be surprised as we
move forward well you're gonna surprise
us with a new suit so shoes yeah shoot
oh there yeah yeah sure no I don't I
would love to see the suit get gold
boots someday oh uh can you know
anything you'd like to see from Kaitlyn
I'm excited for this year I feel like
last year was a great year to explore
her relationship with killer frost and
it's like to see a lot more killer frost
this season see her see killer frost
relationship with everybody in teen
different okay yeah
Tom end us on something weird I know
you're just back there you're dying to
say something yeah well my I guess I
guess what we're all gonna pull it from
this interview he said it's like a it's
a really talented and vivacious and a
very charisma a charismatic group of
people gentlemen step we're all gonna
fight hard together to fill Carlos
Valdes bucket for the next few seasons
it's yeah what a way to put away thank
you so much for stopping by